what's up everyone thanks for checking
out this week in cloud where we serve
you the lowest latency news our Google
cloud platform region in Zurich is now
live and ready for business let's do
this with numbers it's our sixth
European region and our 19th worldwide
and the Zurich GCP region comes with
three availability zones but the coolest
number hosting applications here can
improve latency for Swiss end-users by
up to 10 milliseconds you'll have access
to our flagship products such as Google
compute engine google kubernetes engine
bake query and so on the best of all
thanks to cloud interconnect you can
even access the services that aren't
available in Zurich yet by connecting to
other regions over the Google Network
try it out and reach end users worldwide
you might know that Google wrote the
book on site reliability engineering and
now we're adding some new chapters we've
just added a new Coursera course on sre
to help engineers design and manage
complex systems that meet their
reliability targets basically it
distills everything we've learned
through trial and error about sre since
we coined the term itself these best
practices are tried and true so check
them out not sure where to get started
on these best practices our Google Cloud
partners have access to lots of great
resources including helping you discover
new solutions for your customers and new
channels for your business with Google
cloud our SLO guide is a free resource
for our partners to help companies
discover what they should measure based
on common architectures and critical
user journeys so if you want to see what
being a Google cloud partner can do for
you take a look at the path to becoming
a partner speaking of better sre have
you tried out SEO and see how it can
support your SRU practices check out
this awesome blog from our sto series to
discover how to easily surface
application metrics with SEO and
stackdriver monitoring you'll even learn
how to track the progression of a single
request as it's handled by our other
services in your deployment with stock
driver trace while stock driver logging
can give you a more complete picture of
what your app is doing at all times read
the blog post and try out the hands-on
tutorial for yourself if you want to
read more about these announcements or
see a full list check out the link have
thoughts or ideas leave us a comment or
tweet us we'll see you in the cloud
you